c'était encore les vacances les plus
longues du siècle ah ouais non mais
François Hollande il foutait tellement
rien à l'Élysée qu'il a fait des
vacances plus longues que son quena
d'ailleurs mais je t'ai pas vu toi bah
non toujours là toi sur ma vie on dirait
que tu as pas bougé des dos on dirait on
dirait il a pas bougé tout le monde à
une petite tté tu vois un peu
sympathique tu vois et et franchement
toi on dirait que tu as pas bougé sais
que toi j'ai pensé à toi toutes les
vacances oh merci j'ai trouvé et je te
jure que c'est vrai et ben je pensais à
toi parce que quand il faisait très
mauvais quand je sortais comme ça je
disais il fait un temps Gill verdè sur
toute la France
non mais je vous j que c'est vrai
franchement non mais vraiment et je
pensais à toi tu vois toi par contre tu
as pris des couleurs mais oui alors j'ai
été malade une
semaine j'ai été à 3 et à M donc j'ai
pas attendss quo tu es bonouf c'est le
maquillage ah ouais parce que frère là
franchement bravo
maquilleuse les mec qu'est-ce qui se
passe là ça comm déjà les problèmes
techniques là non faut me le dire il y a
Annabelle qui est avec nous de vilieu
nous fera les prédictions
ch
merci toujours l'aigle ouais un Beaujour
ou peut-être une nuit ça va toi très
bien tu as fait quoi je suis reposé un
petit peu ça fait du bien qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand on on est on voit des
choses on dit quoi on dit voyante on dit
quoi on dit moi je suis médium
clvoyante médium ça veut dire es XX tu
prends
jamais médium donc tu es médium en fait
c'est ça j'ai des flash médium tu as des
flashes quand ça c'est là bam tu
arrivrives bam j'ai un flash moi aussi
j'ai des flash comme ça ah ouais ouais
toi tu vas te
virer
j'ai j'ai des ou j'ai des flash j'ai des
flash vous êtes d'accord avec lui VO pas
ça non mais t'inquiète pas vois ce que
je vois moi sur ce excuse-moi sur ce
dossier là je pense que même si elle est
trèsuse je pense que je vois mieux
qu'elleuse-moi de te dire ça tiens tu V
avoir besoin toi pour une fois B sur
l'affaire Alain Dolon tout ça j'espère
que parce que tu connais l'histoire bah
dès qu'il y a une star en difficulté
bien entendu tu toujours là toujours là
pour l'enfoncer donc heureusement que tu
es là c'est un petit peu pour ça que tu
es là aujourd'hui donc nous déçois pas
là-dessus Benaï alors ça y est qu'est-ce
qui se passe là benim sans déconné tu
croyais qu'on faait des missions au coin
du feu ou quoi non écoute de ma mère
elle a mis un PL la meuf c'est la seule
meuf qui s'habille en PL frère elle est
comm tu rigoles ou quoi elle est venue
dans l'émission arrête un peu elle est
venue bouquiner
frère oh là
là minut oh là là alors je t'ai déjà dit
j'aime pas l'agitation
2024 franchement c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal ben c'est pas mal tu as bouquiné toi
toutes les vacances hein toutes les
vacances bouquin bouquin bouquin B on a
eu les passé on a passé les mêmes
vacances bah je vous ai à chaque fois on
s au téléphone je vous ai recommandé des
livres vous avez tout vu le petit petit
m le petit quoi grand M non mais c'est
vrai c'est un truc de ouf ça va tu as
fait quoi toi euh allez on s'en fout
merci tu nous diras qui t'as invité dans
un instant par que je pense pas que tu
es payé de quoi pourquoi je al ça c'est
curieux qu'on pens t j sur ma vie que tu
payé euh voilà non non attendez attendez
mais pourquoi vous posez toujours des
questions parce que c'est une barre de
fer non ça excusez 2 minutes il y a il y
a un chauffeur de bus là au premier rang
euh les gars s'il doit ramener des
élèves il va les ramener dans un instant
vous inquiétez pas t'inquiète pas mon
chéri j'adore t'inquiète pas non
t'inquiète toi ça va toi toi tu as été à
Rio ouais je sais j'adore le Portugal
euh je suis fou je suis fou de ce pays
Portugal j'adore les Portugais tellement
sympa tu étais tout seul avec ton mec
non non je suis avec des amis je' je
t'ai ramené un petit ramener quoi un
petit souvenir mais c'est pas grandchose
mais c'est une petite clé oh cl la clé
de ton
slip cl de ce que tu veux c'est toi
c'est pas mal et donc ça sert à quoi ça
en fait et ben ça sert à ouvrir les
portes que tu souhait ouvrir mais ça
ouvreraiment une porte cette merde bah
essaye du bonheur il est hyper beau sans
déconner c'est la clé la clé du bonheur
la clé de 2024 c'est vrai et franchement
tu sais que tu es un amour tu as
vraiment pensé à moi quand tu l'as pris
alors je connais cette journée c'est
quand tu es avec des potes tu avec ton
mec et tu dis bon faut quand même qu'on
aille acheté des cadeaux souvenirs à la
famille quand même tu vois on est au
Brésil tout ça donc ils vont dans un
magasin de merde généralement il
s'appelle el chouros ou un truc
comme El chouros et il y a qu'on appelle
chez nous etudiens il y a que des
chouches ça ve dire il y a que des de
mèes et en fait des trucs à un bal de
balles et tiens si on prenait ça pour le
cousin Andy ouais c'est pas mal tu sais
que je vais en prendre une pour cile
pour se la [__] dans le
cul ça s passé comme çactement l'istoire
non franchement tu un amour en tout cas
tu as pensé à moi et c'est l'essentiel
moi aussi j'ai beaucoup pensé à toi
pendant les vacan et donc mon cadeau ton
cadeau ce sera sur ta prochaine fiche de
pain la bonne réponse très bonne réponse
alors c'était bien Rio tout ça le Brésil
quoi vous étiez combi d'
amis C ah ouais ah merde c'est un
chiffre impèire donc forcément pour euh
pourquoi pour des
pingpong un peu relou quoi c'est non
mais c'est vrai qui chiffre impè
forcément ça c'est pas toujours un
problème parfois à TR il avait pas ton
mec si ah il y avait ton mec bien sûr il
était là bien sûr bah bien sûr quoi ça
va il a kiffé ouais adoré c'est préparé
pour minger si j'ai vu qu' allait faire
mat
singer jeadore attends j'adore molo
lasastico arrêtez c'est bon il y a
beaucoup d'émissions en difficulté en ce
moment j'ai pas envie de tirer sur les
amb non c'est vra inger aussi voilà tout
à l'heure bah oui c'est toujours pour
alors pour Laurent sis minger c'est
toujours la dernière étape avant le
chômage j'espère que pour lui ce sera
pas la bah généralement ceux qui sont
juris dans machinger 2 jours 2 mois
après tu les vois pour l'emploi mais
Laurent a du talent donc il va s'en
sortir ce serait bien pour moi alors
quoi d'après ce que vous avez dit ce
serait bien pour moi mais pas to tu vas
y aller directement
pour tu passeras pas par lainger France
merde pas avec ça
fr vasy France ta mère
allez kellvelli comment elle va bonsoir
ça va super alors vous me dites bonsoir
On dirait que je rentre dans une
boulangerie bonsoir à vous qu'est-ce
qu'elle là est-ce qu'on a de la fougasse
ça va vous avez l'air toute contente
ouais ben je suis trop contente de
revenir ça va vous avez eu un des beaux
cadeaux de Noël j'ai eu des beaux
cadeaux j'ai des très beaux cadeaux vous
avez eu notamment ouais des B un beau
robot ah on en parle maintenant bah non
mais je sa pas ce que vous voulez mais
vous avez eu un beau cadeau n on
attendez
elle a eu le
robot elle a eu le robot qu'on voulait
alors attendez attendez attendez j'en ai
offert un à elle et un à sa mère voilà
et votre maman elle vous vou votre maman
alors ça
arrive alors non franchement vous dites
pas merci vous vous croyez que ça tombe
du ciel non mais elle est folle ça tout
le monde voulait le robot elle l'a eu
elle et sa mère et elle vient la laule
gueule en fariné mais mais est-ce que je
peux raconter mon histoire allez-y alors
il y a une émission où vous proposez des
robots à tout va comme ça pour le public
des robots des robots des robots ouis
tout à fait on se dit robot c'est dingue
c'est exceptionnel d'avoir un robot donc
moi ça fait des années que j'attends un
robot avec ma mère on s'est dit c'est
génial c'est un super beau cadeau donc
vous avez lancer un jeu on a envoyé des
sms pour essayer d'avoir un robot comme
tout le
monde bah on a reçu le robot ah oui on
était trop contente TR bien on a déballé
ça vous avez dit quoi quand vous avez
reçu le robot vous AES dit ci est
formidable on s dit mais c'est génial un
robot je par de ma
personne je vous dit c est exceptionnel
il est
généreux il a une un robot deux robots
deux robots un c'est de la famille deux
robots on s'est dit c'est dingue c'est
trop on était gêné bah dites merci bah
attendez ah bah très bien on déballe les
cadeaux on ouvre les boîtes et cetera là
ma mère elle me regarde ouais elle me
dit Kelly je dis bah il y a un problème
elle me dit bah il y a un gros problème
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi
j'aimerais bien savoir bah elle me dit
bah c'est une friteuse
alors
mais c'est une frite elle fait c'est un
c'est un robot qui fait friteuse vous le
dis he c'est un robot friteuse c'est
qu'une friteuse c'est friteuse a Fry
c'est pas du tout le robot dont tout le
monde parle ah oui non c'est une
friteuse le truc et ben avec comme
monsieur vous en avez deux ben ouvrez
une
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
friterie quoi je suis
désolé
désolé non mais c'est quand même un beau
cadeau savez ce qu'elles ont été faire
savez ce qu'elles ont été faireu savez
ce qu'elles ont été faire et c'est ça
c'est ça qui m' c'est ça qui m'a non je
vais le dire au téléspectateurs sil vous
plaî
PL pas du tout elles ont été regardé le
prix elle m'a dit ça vaut 80 balles
combien 80 mais on s'attendait à robot
cuiseur qui fait la cuisine à notre
place COS ch très très ch ils ont été
voir le prix est-ce qu'on va voir les
prix des canadeau tu crois que V aller
voir le prix de ta mère de
moi
VO le prix on a juste vérifié ce qu'on
avait entre les mains c'est tout non
mais écoutez en tout cas merci mais
merci à vous c'était très sympa tu vas
l'utiliser coupp faire frites l'avez
pris chez vous on va faire des te fr
couz vous allez faire
demain demain vous amenez des frites
pour tout le monde je rigole pas vous
allez commencer par que méfiezvous vous
allezut-être rejoindre monel
donc mais du coup ma question c'est
est-ce que le public a pensé comme nous
est-ce que vous êtes mal à l'aise
l'entourloupe du truc est-ce qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui a eu la FR la friteuse
dans le public oui alors heureux heureux
tout le monde tout le monde est content
apparemment ou il y a que vous voilà et
vous avez pas été voir le prix bien
entendu voilà merci
bravoov on voit où sont vos
priorités merci toi ça va toi tu nous a
dit tes vacances c la dépression tu nous
fais chier et puis il y a Annabelle qui
est là non voilà franchement il y a que
qui m'intéressit vous vous êtes
extrêmement puis nous on a déjeuné
ensemble super beaucoup de chance dé
pasqueu pas ouais ouais ouais onel
honneur ou quel honneur bah elle était
là je dis qu'est-ce que tu fous non non
non on a déé on n pas déjeuné en tête à
tête attention il y a avait Lionel Stan
le directeur général de la société et on
l'a invité d'ailleurs mais céit un
déjeuner boulot ou plaisir alors pour
eux boulot pour moi
plaisir mais il me semble quand même moi
ça fait ça fait ça fait quasiment 12 ans
que je suis ici c'est la première fois
que j'entends que vous déjeuner avec
Lionel Stan et un chroniqueur ouais
c'est vrai mais j'en ai de la chance
c'était super on a passé un super moment
ah en plus et c'est que ça bouffe hein
ça ça Bou ah bah je peux vous dire c'est
que ça bouffe hein la recrute BFM je
peux te dire à mon avis elle a dû leur
coûter de l'oseille à la cantine hein
non mais c'est en plus est toute main
c'est tout mais bon [__] elle a un
coup de fourchette mon
frère sur la tête de ma mère je [__]
j'avais à peine démarré le l'entrée
était éta en train de manger un
tiramisou truc de fou hein je dire c'est
un coup de fourchette là les
journalistes comme ça hyper bon j'
non jamais personne il y avait quelqu'un
en face de moi non personne toujours
jamais personne en face de moi quand je
mon que les gens très très propres et
malheureusement ici il en a
pas on va se retrouver dans un
[Applaudissements]
instant